we're here with the very talented tay
diggs
who has written a new children's book
called my friend
which he created with his actual real
life long
time friend illustrator shane evans
now you and shane have been friends
since high school
is that right yes yes we call each other
uh
cousins uh fictive kinship as it were
uh we met in high school school of the
arts
uh in 10th grade and from that point on
we were thick as thieves um we uh
we we graduated high school we went to
the same college together at syracuse we
sang
you know in this band together and uh
and now we're writing children's books
this the whole the whole
the whole idea of writing children's
books came from him
i wrote this poem that he saw in college
and he thought the poem would make a
really good good children's book that
was chocolate me
and he had already been um published
because he's an amazing illustrator
so yeah we just went around the city at
the time going to different publishers
and finally mcmillan picked this up
and then that's where it started so he's
uh
he's like my zen master he's so chill so
cool
um and uh i'm very thankful
very thankful well your collaboration is
really really wonderful and i would like
to bring in someone that i collaborate
with
he is our resident book reviewer who
just so happens to be
young but wise beyond his years
please welcome my friend jonah larson
what's up jonah i drew hi
tay i'm so excited to meet you tayden to
review your books
because i love so many things about them
excellent thank you so much i i truly
appreciate that what do you got to say
my friend
well i wanted to start with the fact
that i love the way
that the books teach they teach about
lecturing
and which is the best way for young
children to learn
but they're also very bright fun
colorful and contemporary
illustrations which really add to the
overall effect of the book
but i love the message especially of my
friend
and for example when one friend pushes
someone down and laughs after he trips
him
the other friend comes over and calls
him out on it and helps him pick up the
kid and brush off his
pants for him and i think that my
message is
so important right now through the times
that our world is currently going
through
and how it's so important that if your
friend or family
member or a relative is doing something
incorrect
you need to call them out on it and have
a real conversation with them
because if you don't you're being
complicit
and when you're being complicit your
silence
is telling them that what they're doing
is okay
but another thing about how fun and
vibrant and contemporary they are
they almost rhyme as you read them out
loud and
i had my dad read it aloud to me and
when he was reading one of your books
i think he was almost rapping while he
was doing it and i was not
i had i had to tell never to do that
again
you sound like my little man yes
yes i am very impressed with you i'm
very impressed
keep it up my friend keep it up you've
got a great use of words and context
so um good for you i'm very impressed
and thank you for the kind words i
appreciate that
oh jonah i just don't know jonah
i know right you're doing a great job
you're doing a great job it's really
oh i just uh uh uh i just got your book
on audible and started listening to it
uh yesterday wildflower
it's awesome it's awesome all right so
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to sit there and take some of my
compliments now
it's really really great i just uh i
just finished green lights
uh matthew mcconaughey's yes and then
immediately
got yours and started yesterday and um
and it is not easy let me tell you to
keep my attention and uh
and you're doing it and it's really
you're good you're you're really good
well done oh my goodness i yeah for real
thank you i i i i'm so honored that
you're listening to it
when i started doing the audio version i
just started laughing and crying and i
stopped and i was like is this okay
are we supposed to do this like more
straightforward
and so great well tay you've brought
so much uh to all of our lives
and particularly myself and jonah
right now today thank you for everything
you're doing and keep it up
keep it up you are just of a bright
light and we we need
more of that so please continue doing
what you're doing thank you
you too jonah thank you so much please
keep writing books because they inspire
so many other kids out there just like
me
thank you well jonah and tay
thank you so much my friend is available
now and all-american
season three airs every monday at 8 7
central on the cw
it's fantastic
[Music]
you